de plus en plus apparemment
comme nous dit
Jean-Luc Bouchard,
de l'émission "La facture".
CLAIRE LAVOIE
- Je regarde des fois
sur Marketplace, et il y a
à des prix intéressants.
- Claire Lavoie, de Gati
a trouvé toute une aubaine :
un iPhone 13 Pro Max
flambant neuf à 700u u u u u u e
vends?" Il dit : "C'est mon
cousin qui me l'é é é é et moi,
je n'en ai pas besoin."
- Elle accepte l'offre,
puis se reninininininininininin.
C'est là qu'on lui apprend
que son téléphone est un faux.
- C'est assez impressionnant.
C'est très, très bien faidededea
boutique FixiPro, aucun doute :
c'est un téléphone Android
bas de gamme.
TAREK SAFAH,
- Le AppStore ne fonctionne pas.
Ici, on a un clandndndndroid.
- À l'intérieur, aucun composant
ne provient d'Apple.
qui est vraie, et les autres,
c'est desssssssses caméras.
- C'est un faux produit
importé de la Chine.
connaît bien la fraude de faux
iPhone. À Montréal seulement,
le service de police traite 175
STEVE BELZIL, commandant, SPVM
- Les fraudeurs comme tel, ça
peut partir de l
dans la jeune vingtaine,
des jeunes adultes. Souvent, ils
vont utiliser un faux profilusux
iPhone en vente dans plu
villes canadiennes, dont
celui-ci. La couleur
ou "black", n'existe pas
pour les iPhones 1x.x.x.x.x.
On devrait plutôt lire
"graphite". Nous donnons
Est-ce que vous savez que vous
avez un fauxososososos mains en
ce moment, un faux téléphone?
- Moi, je ne pense pas que c'est
mon père qui me l'a acheté,
je ns s s s s s pas pourquoi
mon père m'achèterait un faux.-é
ont reçu deux téléphoneseaeaeaet
se départir d'un.
- Parfois, de petits détails
à l'oreille.- - - - - - Le typea
fait remarquer que le "514",
c'est un "S14", et nonaiaiaiaiat
une faute de frappe.
- C'est une fausse facture,
définitivement.
- Plus les offres l l l l l l le
questionner, il faut vérifier.
- Madame Lavoie a porté plainte
à la police, mais elle a
son argent.
- C'est un 1000 $ perdu.
- Ici Jean-Luc Bouchard,